[Music]
all right let's get to it let's go out
to Lexington Kentucky and talk to Kayla
hey Kayla what's
up hi thank you for taking my call of
course hey you had to be on the phone
for a long time sit through all the ads
me talking about meeting corn this
morning so thank you for being patient
of course that's fine so I'll just get
right to it um so my question is how do
I move on with my life without regret
after cutting off contact with my mom I
can tell you right now you
don't regrets gonna be part of this this
journey what
happened um I know what what a bum way
to start to start like like you don't so
T um tell me about it what what happened
with your
mom um so I come from a long line of
um generational sexual trauma
um I was sexually abused by my dad from
the age of
five till about 13 but I mean the end
game doesn't matter um who whoa whoa
whoa every step matters it does I'm
sorry but um thank you hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on I don't want to
leave yet I don't want to leave yet as
the dad of a
daughter who I can't breathe if she's
not okay
I need you to know that was wrong and
I'm sorry on behalf of Dad's everywhere
I'm so
sorry well thank you I appreciate that
your dad should have loved you as much
as I love my little girl I'm
sorry and now I have a little girl who
is the same age I was when all the
trauma started so it's all kind of
getting yep I bet your body is lit up
like a Christmas tree huh exactly yeah
yes and so um
I've actually kind of started the
prosecution process um oh so you're
going for it I'm going for it yeah I've
realized that I'm I'm breaking the
generational curse that has been set on
my
family um but yeah so as the everything
has been coming out and talking I've
kind of realized that my mom has not
taken the steps that I would take for my
daughter now and I just have had a lot
of resentment towards her um like I she
found out in eth grade what was going on
and she stayed with him until I finally
again was like listen I can't do this
anymore I was 21 and I was like I gotta
start getting myself better and I can't
while he's in my life and so um they
ended up divorcing and now as an adult I
had asked her like what was going on
like please try and help me realize why
you didn't leave him at the time and she
told me that well apparently I as an
eighth grader told her that I didn't
want to ruin spring break
plans so I I need you to hear I need you
to hear what I'm going to say very very
clearly okay and hopefully a therapist
has told you this but often I find that
doesn't
happen powerful life altering nervous
system changing drama
happens when one of your parents
sexually abuses
you and Earth shattering nervous system
transforming trauma
happens when you get the courage to tell
another
adult and they do
nothing
yeah I put your mom's violence up
against up right beneath your dad's your
dad did is evil and wrong and it's
disgusting right there's a there's a
grotesqueness to it because it's so
vulgar right what your mom did was
evil because there's a little girl
coming to Mom and saying will you
protect me and she said
nope I'm sticking with the
monster yeah and then all these years
later when you get the courage to go M
what happened she blames
you
yeah like I'm coming out of my skin
right now and I'm trying to be
cool but I hate this happened to
you so actually I'm G to change what I
said earlier you're not going to regret
this forever I was wrong I was 100%
wrong that's what I get for talking too
fast I screwed that
up and I think I'm just battling with so
she's been obviously in my daughter's
life
until just last October okay and so now
I'm just kind of struggling with
the how do I juggle and thankfully like
my daughter has not asked about her she
has she just kind of is going on but I
can tell she can feel the the Hostile
tension that I'm going through right now
so I'm just I'm trying not to I'm just
trying to be the best wife and mom that
I can without letting the trauma
completely take over so here's a couple
of really important things
okay I I want to get this out of the way
you with with all 100% certainty you
need to have a professional walk with
you through this
okay okay all right and I want you to go
to uh look in your local area for a
trauma informed therapist
okay okay and that's a special training
that people go through sometimes it's an
entire program that they go through but
it's a way of looking at responses that
Mak sense it's really where I mean that
was a lot of my training was there and
that's why I don't I tell people no
you're not broken your body's working
great considering what happened to you
okay so that's number one I want to put
that off to the side for a second okay
um how old's your
daughter she's five
okay your gut instinct is going to be to
shield and protect her
yes and what she is going to do is she's
going to absorb the tension that you are
feeling walking re walking through hell
right you're walking through it with a
sword this time but it's still going to
be back through
hell right you're going to have to go
through old memories you're going to get
deposed you're going to have your dad's
lawyer if he decides to be even a
further pathetic coward decides to get
one and try to fight you and call you a
liar you're going to have to go through
all those old stories and have people
question and your integrity and go
through a high school boyfriend you're
have to go through all
that the problem is if you're not it's
going you're going to be walking a fine
line I'll I'll talk you through it here
but you're going to have to let your
daughter know that the tension you are
experiencing has zero to do with
her otherwise she's going to do what you
did which is feel that tension in the
home make it your problem to
solve right and so that regret that you
feel is you have been protecting your
mom your whole
life you've been making sure your mom is
okay or doesn't get mad or doesn't find
out your whole life because when your
mom
says um no I'm good I'm going stay with
him that little girl doesn't immediately
go my mom is
evil it goes oh what did I do how do I
fix
this right right and that was never your
job job to fix but what we don't want to
do that's how trauma gets transferred
either the act the ACT goes with it
right you abuse somebody which you're
never going to do or right that inner
chaos that inner turmoil that you you
are fighting and scratching and clawing
every second of every day to give your
daughter something you didn't have but
that angst and tension she
absorbs and so it's letting her know
Mommy is really scared today she has to
go do some hard scary things what Mom
well I have to have some scary
conversations with some big grown-ups
that were mean to me when I were
little what happened well that's
grown-up
stuff but I want you to know that every
day I wake up I'm so grateful that God
let me be your
mommy you see what I'm saying and what
we're doing is we're going to normalize
no sometimes your body feels especially
when you're doing scary hard stuff uh
your body reacts a certain way that's
normal that does not impact my love for
you and so it's going to be weird for
you talking through it because nobody's
ever modeled that for you ever right
right right and you don't want to go too
far and be like your grandfather like
she's not ready for that cuz she's five
there will become a SE there will become
time when you when you tell your story
to your
daughter it's just not
now and so tell me about your tell me
about your
mom now is she fighting you does she
want to see her she giving you grief
about babies like how how is all that
working
out no
she's I think she's just kind of I
talked to my brother um a few days ago
and he got to he saw her over um new
years's and I guess she told him that
well she thought it was going to be a
little bit hard at first but it's it's
not as hard as she thought having me cut
her off so that was kind of um I guess
the cherry on the the cake for me
is such a coward I don't know but an
abolute coward it's just and I don't
mean to talk bad about your mom but I
sure mean to talk bad about your your
mom yeah unbelievable it's just kind of
a smack in the face because it's like
okay I understand and it all kind of
came to a head when
I so she's remarried now and one of my
um step sisters was actually dating a
pedophile and we all went to the wedding
and come to find out I I didn't know any
of this so she kind
of I
guess just let me bring my daughter
around a pedophile and everybody knew
except me and come to find out they were
all like oh no we can't tell her we
can't tell her what's going on um but
yeah I
just there's just been so many different
layers and so with that finding out that
she knew that there was a pedophile
present who was on the sex offenders
list and didn't feel the need to tell me
so I could take the actions into my own
hands whether that be not going to the
wedding or something and so that's when
I kind of was like okay I've I've known
my whole life that I wasn't going to be
protected by anybody and now that I'm a
doll I can protect myself and now it's
my job to protect my daughter and so
good dude that you have turned it this
is what that looks
like I need you to hear me kale you have
changed everything this is what that
looks
like as the great Terence Terence real
says it just oh it's brutal here's what
he says and I love this quote I'm going
to butcher it a little bit but um Family
trauma rolls down a hill like a forest
fire until one brave soul stops and
turns and stares it
down and gives peace to Future ancestors
they may never
know what gets left out of that famous
quote is uh and again I I messed it up
but that sentiment is is a person who
stops and stares down a forest fire gets
burned badly and that's
you you have to deal with the the pain
of your mom going yeah I don't care he
was sleeping with my husband when she
was young good for
her right you got to deal with a mom
that didn't even step between you and a
monster she chose a monster you got to
you gotta all of it all of it I could
just go through I'm not going to torture
you with that
and so then you have the brother going
well I don't know man or the sister
being like well come
on this is what staring down a forest
fire looks like so I think the the pain
you are feeling is
grief and I don't know that you've ever
been allowed to sit in grief because
you've been too busy trying to keep
yourself
safe right is your husband a good
man yes he is he's the one that
introduced me to your show yeah he's
he's amazing then he must be the best
guy ever um when you're
safe you can grieve and here's why
that's going to be hard for you grief
would get you hurt in the past you
didn't have time for
grief you're too busy trying to protect
yourself from the two freaking people
who are supposed to love you the
most and so this pain you feel isn't
regret you might it might feel bad if
you
will but just because it hurts doesn't
mean it's not the exact right
thing and I'm pretty slow on the just
cut people up I'm telling you right now
I don't see a path forward where I would
ever talk to that woman
again yeah and what that means is you
got to live in a
world your mom's not going to be there
for you because she opt it out hear me
very clearly you did not sever this
relationship she
did she left
you so if someone's in your home and
they smash up your house and they run
out at the front door and get in their
car and
leave just because you closed the door
doesn't mean you kicked them
out right all you're doing here is
closing the
door your mom's burned your house to the
ground enough she got in her car with a
monster and took
off so what it looks like now moving
forward is just a season of hellacious
grief it's gonna
suck yeah okay that's why I need you to
promise me you're going to get with a
trauma counselor who will walk with you
I'm going to send you my book own your
past change your future it's about this
very thing not sexual abuse as much as
when everything falls apart I had this
picture of what my life was going to
look like in this scary scary question
what am I going to do now and dude
you're already
there you're sitting with police
officers you're going to make sure this
man um cannot hurt any more people
moving forward and is held accountable
for what he did in the
past you're on your way but we often see
The Bravery story and the strength story
and we don't realize how lonely that is
or how scary that is or how much that
hurts and that's a part of this journey
too
I want you to also pick up a book called
Finding meaning by David Kessler it's
the best book on Grief I've ever
read it's a
masterpiece but it will walk you through
some steps and I've talked about all the
time writing yourself letters um uh
making sure you have a daily journaling
practice making sure you've got somebody
that you can call in the middle of the
night as this stuff starts to resurface
it's going to be gnarly and as your
daughter continues to enter into ages
when this stuff happened to you your
body has put a GPS pin in that and it's
going to go young girl young girl look
out look it's just going to start
radiating and people are going to come
over well-meaning people kind people and
your body's going to just be alarm
Central it's okay you're not broken it's
normal there's nothing wrong with you
but we do need to do the work
to learn a new way to respond to some of
those things that's just part of where
you're at but I don't think you're going
to feel regret what you're doing is
right you didn't kick anybody out they
burned your house down and then walked
out with the remaining door frame you
just with the remaining door frame you
just closed the
door I'm proud of you Caleb proud of you
hang on and we'll get you hooked
up